Selam
bu gün sizlere kısaca
o Herkes bir şeylerden bahsetti
eskilerin bir lafı var bu Gök kubbenin
altında Söylenmemiş laf kalmadı galiba
ha geçmişten bugüne Ben neden söz
edeceğim ben de düşündüm ki Söylenmemiş
bir şey olabilir o da benim şahsi
hayatım ve bu hayatta edindik lerim diye
düşündüm Onun için de size Bugün kendi
kişisel deneyimlerinden yola çıkarak
edindikleri mi Doğru yaptığımı
düşündüklerimi yaptığım hataları ve bana
referans olanları 15 dakikalık bir zaman
diliminde Anlatmaya çalışacağım biraz
damıtarak biraz yılı tarak ben size
küçük bir adımla başlamak istiyorum ben
ilkokul dördüncü sınıftaydım benim
hayatımda öyle çok fazla etkili öğretmen
olmadı ve birçok dersi de görmedim
12 bin nüfuslu ilçeler ise bitirdim
elektriği lise son sınıfta suyun
musluktan aklında üniversitede gördüm
ben
ne böyle çok acımayın bana canım Geçen
hafta da Avrupa'da seyahat dedim Hani
öyle çok da acınacak pozisyonum yok
o orada Ruhi Hanım diye bir müdür
yardımcısı bir kadın vardı kocası küçük
ilçenin Kaymakamı ydı beni sevmişti ve
bana bir rol vermişti şeyde bir
tiyatroda 4 sınıfta Ender okul
anılarından bir tanesidir çıkıyordum
böyle sahneye ve bağırıyordum en sonda
çıkıyordum Çok yetenekli değildin galiba
bu çağdaş uygarlık düzeyine çıkacağız
diye böyle bir bağırıp ediyordu
bunun defa yaptım belki hatırladığım tek
şey bu sonra ben bunu yaptıkça hoşuma
gidiyordu ve ki akşamları evde
düşünüyordum bu çağdaş uygarlık düzeyine
biz nasıl çıkacağız
Bir merdiven bu hayal ederdim o merdiven
pınardır bulutların üstüne çıkardım
orada uygarlık diye bir şey hayal
ederdim orada falan oraya çıkardım
inerdim böyle Hadi her gece Hayır hoşuma
giderdi uygarlık ve Yukarıda bir yerde
zannediyordum gökyüzünde sonra Bitti
falan filan çok kız 15 dakika uzun
hikaye var Sonuna geleyim ben ikinci kez
Üniversite okurken tekrar taktım bu
Uygarlık nedir kardeşim Uygar insan
kimdir diye sordum öyle anlı şanlı
profesörlere sordum hocam dedim ya işte
Medeni insandır Sedacım falan filan işte
uygarlığı ya hocam Tamam da ben Uygar
mıyım değil mi Nereden anlayacağım Bunu
ben uygularım insan olmak istiyorum bu
istiyorum merdiven koyduk bir sürü şey
falan filan çok uzun hikaye Kimse
bilmedi burada kimsenin bildiğini tahmin
etmiyorum Bu tanımı iddialı söyleyeceğim
mi Evet Uygar İnsan kendi hayatını
güzelleştirip kolaylaştıracak ne kadar
beceriye sahip s bir insan o kadar
uygarlığıdır bugünkü konuşmaların
içerisinde Aslında size söylenenlerin
içerisinde bu vardı bunu ikinci bir
özelliği var
mı başka insanların hayatını da
güzelleştirip kolaylaştıracak becerilere
dolanırsa tamamen uygarlığıdır bugünkü
konuşmalardan ne var dikkat ederseniz
baştaki delikanlı şeyden bahsetti bize
ayrımcılıktan bahsetti değil mi
nefretten sonra cinsiyetçilik ten sonra
hayvan haklarından hepsi
başkalarının hayatlarını güzelleştirip
kolaylaştıracak beceriler dibi Rock
hanımefendi çıktı burada sosyal
işlerinden bahsetti başkalarının bütün
bize söyledikleri Uygar insanın
özellikleri ydi Uygar insanın iki tane
tanımı var Onun için kendi hayatınızı ne
kadar güzelleştiriyor sanız ve
başkalarının hayatını kadar
güzelleştirip kolaylaştırıyor sanız o
kadar uygularsınız topluma çevirirsek
uzun sürer anlatırım ama okumak Onun
için uygarlık açısından bir ölçüttür
Çünkü okuyan insanın hayatı güzelleşir
Co ve sanat onun içindir başkalarının
sanatçılara Niye daha Uygar işler
diyoruz onun içindir buluşlar
bilimadamları niye uygarlığın ölçüleri
dir Evet odur şu bombayı atan bombayı
bulanları Daha doğrusu atomu parçalayan
lar uygarlığı Evet hizmet ettiler ama
bombayı patlatanlar değil bu
Ben buradan size şuraya gelmek istiyorum
Bu bir şey çok mutlu oldum Benim sunum
saçma sapan bir soru değilmiş ilk defa
TED konuşması yapın Çünkü çalıştır
bazılarıyla benden önce ne daha Efendim
ismi
bi hayır hayır psikolog Efendi Serap
hanım da özür diliyorum kablo Kadir ve
okula geliyorum hafızam en zayıf adamla
adam verirsin bunu değil beni maymun çok
uğraştı sağolsun isimleri ezberle
yemedim Evet hayat böyle bir şey
ve bu aşağıdaki giderek azalıyor Dünyada
daha önce böyleydi bu
bu pardon şu altta gördüğünüz kırmızı
çizgi gibiydi Hayatlar giderek
Yukarıdaki hale geldi hanımefendi de
gösterdi size
ya ben bu arada bir şey söyleyeceğim Ben
teorik bilgisi çok zayıf bir adamım
ama ben uygulama acım özgeçmişinde
söylediler okuduklarımı değil
yaptıklarım ve yaşadıklarımı sizinle
paylaşıyorum
bu onun için yaptıklarımı yaşadıklarımın
bilimle çelişen tarafları olabilir özür
diliyorum bilimsel bir konuşma
yapmadığının altını çizmek istiyorum ama
gördüğüm kendi hayatımda bu
Ya hayatım Bak ilk etapta böyle ucuz
kırmızı çizgi durumu azaldığı ve giderek
böyle bir zikzak aldı
bu hayatta hepimizin hayatı böyle olacak
ve böyle giderek böyle olacak Bunu zor
bir tak bunu ne böyle olsun öbür türlü
olsun artık bu yok
o
ölürüm daha iyi olur buna Bunu tercih
etmek istiyorsanız bile onunla baş
etmeniz gerekiyor zikzak larla demin
gösterdi size hanımefendi dizi düz
hayattan çıkışlar var artık evet
Bu nedir bu zikzaklar diye soracak
olursanız bugün çok konuşuyoruz ekonomik
kriz Savaş şu bu falan filan Vallahi ben
size söyleyeyim ben çok etkileniyorum
Ya ben çünkü gördüm bunları Bunlar
olağan şeyler
oluyor olmaya devam edecek bitecek bir
daha olacak
ve ona karşı duruşunu önemli geriye
gideceğim
ve bu becerilere don alırsanız hepsini
baş edersiniz Merak etmeyin asla olan bu
bu meteorolojide başka bir şey gelir hiç
merak etmeyin Ukrayna Savaşı biter başka
bir yerde de başlar bununla baş
edebilecek becerilere sahip misiniz o
yoksa kriz geliyor teknoloji değişiyor
falan filan bunlar için çok şey arkada
bu var haberiniz olsun
bu onun için bunu odaklanın
Ve bu zikzaklar çok o benimkinde oldu
Seninkinde olacak hemen İstanbul'da her
gün hayatınızı kurtaracak zaten oluyor
Sen bunla baş edecek becerilere
bağlanmanız gerekiyor sabahleyin bir
hanfendi söyle dismo dedi Ne dedi
problem çözme falan filan problem çözme
insanların varlığından beri aranan bir
beceridir yeni bir şey değildir
ama bugünün becerisi değildir
bir insanlık var olduğu sürece problem
çözme becerisi olan herkes bu hayatla
bezi kızaklarla baş etmiştir bugünün
özelliklerinden değildir bilginiz olsun
öyle bazen söylüyorlar ben de karşı
söyleyeceğim 21'inci Yüzyıl becerileri
falan filan kayda geçiyor bu Kadir Bey
Evet kötü bir şey ama hep söyleyeceğiz
artık Evet 21 yüzyıl becerisi diye falan
filan bir saçmalık yok arkadaşlar
söyleyeyim burada 21o becerilerin Hepsi
18 yüzyılda geçerli becerilerde Orada
onlara sahip olanlar öndeydi başarılıydı
kendi hayatlarının güzelleştirip
kolaylaştırıyor vardı başkalarının
hayatını güzelleştir kolaylaştırıyor
lardı
Ben onun o zaman da geçirdi o zaman da
geçerli Belki bugün biraz daha yaygın
aşabilir bilmiyorum
bu peki
ama ben kendi hayatımda önemli bir şeyi
öğrendiğim ve uyguladığım bir şey daha
paylaşmak istiyorum sizinle
ve bu zikzak laba baş etmek açısından ve
biraz önce bahsettiğim o
hayatla daha Uygar olmayla hayatımı
güzelleştirecek ve kolaylaştıracak
becerileri edilmekle alakalı alın e Beni
en çok etkiledi neye dikkat ettim onu
paylaşmak istiyorum doğduğum gün değil
tabi bugün dönüp baktığımda edindik
lerim Bu arada hiç kimseye de
yaptıklarımı tavsiye etmem haberiniz
olsun isteyen etkilenir Bir nasihat gibi
algılamayın Lütfen bu söylediklerimi
yaşadıklarımı paylaşıyorum sizinle sizde
öyle yapın gibi bir iddiam Haşa mümkün
değil öyle bir şey haddim değil oralarda
olduğumu da düşünmüyorum
O hep kızıma teşekkür edeceğim sana
olmamış
bu eikonal
var Birincisi
yapabileceğimizin en iyisini yapmaya
çalıştım
bu burada demin burada bir çocuk gördük
ne ismi Fırat heyecanlıydı Evet o da onu
yapmış tebrik ediyorum Fırat
305 yapabileceğinin en iyisini yapmak
Nerede o unutmayın eylemde
gerçeklikte
teşehhüde değil hayalde değil hayalde
sınırsız olun Kabe size anlatamam Ben
dünya yönetim kaç defa Hayallerim ama
eylemde Hadi geçtik en iyisini yapmak
Ben uygulama acım onun için söylüyorum
bunu bu eylemde en iyisini yapmak
yaptığımda
Bu bir Yeni Bir Başlangıç fırsatı buldum
bu çok önemli bir şey ideal olmuyor diye
eylemden vazgeçtim her zaman kaybettim
Ben kafamda tasarladığım gerçekleşmiyor
diye her geri çekildiğinde kaybettim ama
yapabileceğimizin en iyisini yapmaya
kalktığımda hep kazandım
benden kaybettim bir bilseniz
mi Evet
değil mi Delikanlı çalışıyordu Ben de
ona bunu söyledim Serap bir de bunu bana
söyle Çok iyi oldu dedi Niye dedim ben
hemen dedi gidip sevgilim dediği evlenme
teklif edeceğim diye hayal ettim
yapamadığım için ilk Elif edemiyordum
dedi ne yapabilirsem onu yapacağım gitti
söyledi Efendim olmadı kız kabul etmişti
biraz zor Ama kabul etmişti bu önemli
bir şey Yeni Başlangıç benim açımdan
fark ettim
bir adım adım geri döneceğim O delikanlı
lan ben etkilendim Fırat öyle yapmış
her en iyisi yapabildiğin de yeni bir
şey açılmış yeni yeni yeni yeni Cesur
olduğum her zaman kazandım
Çok korktum her zaman kaybettim
ve her korkunun bir bedeli oldu her
cesaretimin bir
Kazancı oldu ben orada oturuyorum Efendi
onun yaşadığını Ben 28 yaşında yaşadım
gidip dönercide sipariş verememişti Ben
28 yaşında Evet
bu İstanbul'a ilk geldiğimde bir
restoranda başarıyla sipariş verip
hesabı da garsondan bir fırça yemeden
başarıyla kalktığımda kendini çok mutlu
hissetmiştim
O hep cesaret deyince bizim ülkemizde
sokağa çıkıp bilgilerini dövmek ya da 8
katlı bir apartmanda atlamak olarak
algılanıyor maalesef birilerine iki
yumruk atmak ya da belinde silah taşımak
olarak algılanıyor cesaret Keşke ben
öğrenmeseydim çok fark ettim geç fark
ettim bu cesaretin ne demek olduğunu
cesaret korkusuzca gidip bir ise
tanışmak tır cesaret
Evet Ee herhangi gitti bir ortamda
ayrılmayacağını düşünmeden de
konuşmaktır cesaret parasız kalıp geriye
seyahat edebilmektir
cesaret bir şeyler yazmaya kalkışmak tır
cesaretten kastım budur
o cesaret açıkçası toplumun onaylı bazı
durumlarda hiçe saymaktır bazı
durumlarda diyorum dikkat etmeniz
çekerim
bu
onun için cesaret bana hep Cesur Ken
kazandım kaybetti ikincisi çaba
O bana ait bir laf vardır söyleyeceğim
Bu dünyada korkakların ve tembellerin
başardı bir iş görmedim
bu onun için çaba önemli bir durum gene
Fırat Benim şeyim Çünkü Somut bir işte
çıktı hanımefendi burada oturuyor öyle
sosyal bir girişimci ikisi çaba ha
cesaret ve çaba göstermişler ben de
onların kimi yaptığımda kazandım
yapmadım da kaybettim bazen Cesur
olacaksınız bazen korkacaksınız sürekli
Cesur olmak Hayır sürekli çaba harcadı
iş tembellik hakkını kullanmak olabilir
mi yani herkeste var mı orijinal olmak
Evet küçük büyük fark etmez bana ait
olanları sizinle paylaşıyorum çok iyi ya
beni Eskiden göreceksiniz Ben 15 sene
önce konuşmayı bıraktım biliyor musunuz
diye bıraktım konuşmayı onun laflarını
getirip başkasını anlatmaktan bıktım
baktım hiçbir etkisi de olmuyor Peter
dururken şöyle söylemiş O buradan gelmiş
Aristo böyle getirmiş falan filan
onlarında Biz başkalarına söylüyorduk 15
sene önce ben konuşup konuşmaya karar
verdim Bu yüzden
bu orijinal size ait olan güzeldir
orijinal biri shorty orjinal deyince Biz
de şey zanneder bir yaratıcılık bir
orijinallik iki bu ikisinden de böyle
çok büyük şeyler ben bunu yapamam
duygusu vardı bende sağolsun Aytaç
çocuğa gelmemi sağladı onun küçük bir
şey orjinali sabahleyin Aslında hepimiz
orjinal almaya çalışıyorsunuz Nerede o
aynanın başında
hele kadınlar
Ne oldu oldu kadar saygı duyulacak bir
şey yok
var yani Benim evdeki gibi üç kadın bir
arada olunca İki kız bir hanım zor
oluyor beklemesi ama var çok saygı
duyuyorum bu kendilerine gösterdikleri
Özen o orijinal olma durumu başkasına
benzememe durumu a12 yapmış falan filan
pişti olmayayım gibi falan Laflar var
Evet bir orijinallik budur Bu
öyle de çok abartmamak gerektiğini
anladığımdan itibaren orjinal işler
yapmaya başladım böyle bir yazarlar
falan ya bir tane kitap yazdım
bir öğretmen kitabı yazdım bir
arkadaşımla beraber yıllar önce ama onu
da orjinal yazdık sağ olsun artık çocuğa
2000'li kalan dışına atanan öğretmenler
vardı gittik sorduk ne ihtiyacınıza göre
gibi çocukları oynatmayı bilmiyoruz
orman mühendisi Efendim avukatı falan
öğretmen yapmıştım Biz kalktık olur oyun
yazdık verdik kitabı çok sattı başka
hocaların Barajı kızlar Biz ikiye Samet
orjinal bir şey yaz bütün bunlarla
beraber unutmayın herşeyin eskisi vardır
bunu anladım Böyle zıpladım ben o ben
burada bir soba
ve orjinallik bir şey yeniden yapmak
değildir kendinizi yormayın Her şeyin
bir etkisi var
orjinallik onun üstüne ya da iki yeni
şehir üstüne birleştirmek üstüne küçük
bir şey koymaktır Kendinizi çok
zorlamayın
bu herşeyi Bak dünyada bildiğiniz
kullandığımız Her şeyin bir geçmişi
vardır beni dinlemezler bir gün bir
Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı beni dinlersen
ona bir şey söyleyeceğim nesnelerin
tarihi diye bir ders koy diyeceğim ben
üzerinde oturduğunuz koltuk ilk nasıl
icat edilmiş gidin bir bakın
ya bildiğiniz araba öyle falan filan
Bunların hepsi birbiriyle bağlantı o
tekerleği icat eden yapabileceğinin en
iyisini yapmaya çalışmasaydı Siz bugün
aramalara bilemezsiniz onu yaptığı bir
üstüne bunu koydu öbürü bilmem ne bilmem
ne Kardeşler gitti uçağı oldu bende dün
akşam geldim onunla
o ilk yapan sen değil
o unutmayın Ben
dünyada galiba araç çok sayıda
birbirinden farklı eğitim kurumu gördüm
He he bağdatta gördüm orak ta Suriye'de
gördüm İngiltere'de ettin kalıcı gördüm
Harvard gördüm ya Üniversitesi'ni gördüm
Avusturya'da çok gördüm Almanya'da
gördüm bir sürü yerde bir sürü o Gördüm
Hiçbiri de öbürüne benzemiyor birbirine
benzeyen ilkeler var Sonra özgeçmişimde
okudular galiba değil ben duymadım orada
yazıyor enerji sektöründe de ben
çalıştım Şu anda da çalışıyorum Bir
Holding'in en üstte yöneticiliğini
yaptığım bir dönem dört yıl kadar orada
sektörle ilgili çok gittim gördüm gezdim
farklı sektörlerden insanlarla tanıştım
farklı ülkelere gittim orada da baktım
ettim falan filan Şimdi sonunda
Ben size bir şey söyleyeceğim bütün bu
gördüklerimden özet olarak Bu nota
dediğimiz 8 nota do re mi fa sol la si
do falan diye gider hepimizin gördüğü
bunu Tan'ın tarihi Kimisi sümerlere
dayandırıyor Bilmem 2500 yıl diyor
o kimse diyor ki bunu ilk Pisagor bulmuş
işte
Demirciler demiri döverken sesi duymuş
falan filan ki ama en yenisini orta
çağırıyor yani 600 yıl falan Hayat
İçinde bulunduğumuz koşullara göre
tüm Bu koşullar
Bahçeşehir'de başka Bağcılar'da başka
Şemdinli'de başka ikizderede başka
Ben Hollanda Amsterdam da başka
Viyana'da başka Avusturya'da tillo'da
başka ama hepimizin kendi Bulunduğunuz
koşullar içerisinde hepimize 8 tane nota
vardır
bu evimiz 8.30 biliyoruz Bu sekiz
noktayı kullanarak biz
bu Mozart olmuş olabilirsiniz
var ama dikkat edin Mozart'ın isminin
ikinci hecesi olmayın Çok teşekkür
ediyorum beni dinlediğiniz için
[Alkış]